[MUSICAL TONE]
All right, y'all.
It is an absolute
trip to be here
at RStudio Conference
talking to all of you
about the R for Data Science
Online Learning Community,
sharing a little bit
about my personal story,
and then talking about
diversity, equity,
and inclusion in data science.
And that's a lot to cover
in the next 15-20 minutes,
but we can do it.
The reason this is
so wild to be here
is that this is not something
that kids like me traditionally
grow up and do.
I grew up to a poor,
working-class family
outside of Buffalo, New York.
And I am the first
and only person
in my family to both go to
and graduate from college.
And I really liked college
so much that I ended up
going to graduate school twice.
And I did college at the--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
People feel me.
I can tell already.
I did college at the
"education at any cost" model.
To give you some perspective,
I graduated from high school
in 1999, but I took
eight years to finish
my undergrad, which
means I graduated
into the recession of 2008.
So there were lots of jobs
for people with degrees.
So I have a ton
of student loans.
I went through a
variety of careers.
I did academia for
a little while.
And I ultimately ended up
teaching high school science,
and I loved it.
But I'm not sure
if you know this.
Teaching doesn't pay the bills.
It is an amazing career.
I recommend it for everybody.
But if you are carrying six
figures worth of student loan
debt, teaching is
probably not going
to help you make ends meet.
So I was in this
position in about 2014
where I was evaluating my life.
And I knew a couple of things.
One-- I really
liked video games.
And to be very specific, I
really liked World of Warcraft.
And to be even more specific,
in the spirit of vulnerability,
I could play World of Warcraft
for like 12 to 15 hours a day.
So there were some things
going on in my life.
But I really liked video games.
[LAUGHING]
Really liked video
games, and data science
was becoming a thing.
And it didn't seem like a fad,
but data science was like, OK,
I have some background
that could maybe
put me in a position where
I could do data science.
And guess what?
I don't think I need to go
back to school to become a data
scientist.
So I think that maybe
I could do this thing.
I could be a data
scientist and I could
change my financial future.
So through a variety of weird
coincidences and situations,
I found myself interviewing
for this nebulously defined
data-ish position with an
eSports startup based out
of Dallas, Texas
called PvP Live.
To this day, I don't know where
I got the courage to tell them
I was a data scientist.
I don't.
I was registered in the
Johns Hopkins Data Science
specialization from Coursera,
but I took none of the classes.
Like most of you here, I'm sure.
And I had taken a graduate
level statistics course
for one semester, and I knew a
little bit about this language
called R.
But the fact remains
that I knew more
about data science than
anybody at the company,
so nobody knew that maybe
I wasn't a data scientist.
So I said, I am
a data scientist.
And they hired me.
So I worked remotely
for a while,
and then they told me to move
to Dallas or find a new job,
so I moved to Dallas.
And my first day on the
job, they were like,
congratulations.
You're a manager.
And I was like, cool.
Maybe I don't even need
to learn data science.
You know?
I'll just manage
data scientists.
So that was really cool.
And then six months
on the job, I'm
spending more and more of my
time managing data scientists
and helping them
learn data science.
And I'm learning a
little bit as I go,
but really I'm learning a
lot about managing and being
at a startup.
And this is six months
in the job and it's new
and it's exciting,
and this is amazing.
I told this company I
was a data scientist,
and they hired me
as a data scientist.
And then they promoted me as
a manager of data scientists.
And I was like, this is so easy.
You just tell people
you're a data scientist
and they hire you.
So 12 months into the
job, without warning
and without notice, they
let us go without pay.
And that is something
of a misnomer,
because they told me
I could have equity.
But if your company
makes zero revenue,
your equity is still zero.
I knew enough math to
know that this was not
going to work out in my favor.
So I'm in Dallas.
I've renewed my lease.
I've gambled everything
on data science
and this eSports startup,
and I've kind of lost.
So what do I do?
Do I go back to teaching?
I know teaching is not
going to pay the bills,
but I know I love it.
But then I've got to
get certified in Texas,
and that's a process.
Or do I try to find something
data-related or data adjacent?
And I decided to see what
I could do with data.
And maybe let go of the
data scientist title.
Does it matter if I'm
called a data scientist,
or does it matter if
I'm working with data?
And I was like, well,
I guess it matters
that I'm working with data.
But this time, I'm going
to work for a company
that I believe in.
I did believe in the
eSports startup for a while.
But I was like, I need someone
with a little more clout.
So I ended up working for the
Girl Scouts of Northeast Texas.
And ultimately, at Teaching
Trust, which is where I am now.
And I do strongly recommend
working for nonprofits
to start getting your feet
wet with data-related careers.
I've had all sorts of titles.
I've been an analyst.
I've been in research
and evaluation.
I've been in outcomes.
And as long as you let go of
that data scientist title,
I think that you can get
started with data science
just about anywhere.
So I was in this position
where I'm working in nonprofits
and I'm doing analytical work,
but I'm moving into management.
It turns out once
you're a manager,
it's hard to not be
a manager ever again.
Because people are like oh, no.
We just want you to manage.
So I'm here, and I'm
leveling up on the side.
And I'm like, I
want to get better
at R. I kind of
know this language.
I think it's really useful.
I think it can make a lot
of what I do at work better.
So as an educator,
I was like, I'm
going to teach myself R. I'm
going to get better at this,
but I'm going to be
transparent about my process,
and I'm going to share that
process with other people.
So I took to social
media and Twitter,
and I was tweeting about things,
and I was writing blog posts.
And my first blog
posts were helping
people navigate that gap between
using your computer for Netflix
and using your computer
to do data science.
And forget the gap
between Excel and R.
The gap between using
your computer for Netflix
and the gap between navigating
RStudio is very, very real.
And people need those resources.
So as I was doing this,
two things happened.
Someone on Twitter
was like, there
is this really good book
called R for Data Science,
and it's free.
And I was like, oh, cool.
I will read the book.
But then Hadley retweeted me.
And this is the most popular
I've ever been on Twitter.
It's probably the most popular
I will ever be on Twitter,
and that's OK.
But I was benefiting
from something
that, for some
people, we informally
refer to as the
"Hadley bump," right?
For 15 minutes, this is my
15 minutes of fame, right?
And I'm like, I can take
this and run with it,
or I can forget about it.
People are interested
in what I have
to say for a limited
amount of time,
so I have the opportunity to
take this book that I'm going
to read anyway, and why
not invite other people
to read it with me?
So that was how the R for
Data Science Online Learning
Community-- the concept started.
But when Hadley
retweets you, you
have a limited
amount of time to get
people still interested
in what you're saying.
I can't wait two weeks and
come back and be like, hey,
I have this cool idea.
You have to move.
So it's all about finding
your opportunities, people.
So I have to come
up with this plan.
And my idea is like,
well, I don't want
to spend any money on this.
And I don't want
anybody else to have
to spend any money on this.
We shouldn't have to
spend money to learn
how to do data science.
We're repurposing things
we already know how to do.
So I was like, it's
going to be free.
It's going to be open to whoever
wants to be a part of it.
And so the original idea was,
let's create a Slack group
and let's follow this
curriculum map that
goes through maybe two chapters
of the textbook every week.
And we'll finish in
three to four months,
and we'll all be data
scientists at the end.
We'll be pros.
We'll be total experts.
It's going to be amazing.
And one thing we did with
this group that I think
is different from some
other online learning
communities is that
we made it very clear
that you had to
be nice to people.
And you would be kicked
out if you weren't nice.
This was going to be the kind
of place where you could come
and you could say, I only
have two panes in RStudio,
and I know I'm
supposed to have four,
and I don't know what to do.
And instead of someone
being like, loser.
You're so new at this.
People would be like,
hey, you know what?
I can help you with that.
And I'm going to stick with
you until we figure that out.
And so that was the idea
for the kind of people
you were going to encounter.
And then lastly,
we had this idea
of there being
mentors and learners.
So you self-identified.
Am I here to mentor other people
in their learning journey,
or am I here to learn?
And maybe you were a learner
for the first three chapters,
and then you became a
mentor for other things.
So it was this very
fluid definition.
We weren't going to say,
oh, we've done this survey
and you are a mentor
and you are a learner.
You got to identify.
You got to take responsibility
for your role in the community.
So expectations versus reality.
I could on about this--
I've got like three hours
of material on this.
I will keep it brief.
Essentially I was
like, no one's going
to want to do this with me.
This is an awful
idea, but why not try?
I figured at the
end of two weeks,
I'd be begging my friends
to do this with me.
There'd be 12 of us,
maybe 25, maybe 50
in this online
learning community.
And I'm like, that's fine.
That's fine.
It's fine.
At the end of two weeks
when the invites went out,
we had over 600 members.
Which for me meant that I'm
not there as a learner anymore.
I'm there as a
community manager.
And that was a surprise.
That was something
I wasn't expecting.
But as we moved
into things and I
started thinking about what
worked and what didn't work,
there was a lot.
But I would say
of the 600 people,
within the first two weeks,
we lost half of our members.
And we lost our members
for one of two reasons.
One-- Slack was overwhelming.
Right?
Most of us probably use
Slack and we're like,
oh, I'm so tired of this tool.
It's amazing, but
stop sending me stuff.
But you know how to navigate it.
Not everybody knows
how to navigate Slack.
Not everybody knows how to
turn their notifications off.
And when you log in and all of
a sudden there's 450 messages,
you're done.
You are out.
Right?
But we also had people who
couldn't install or navigate
R and RStudio.
And that's where we
lost 50% of our members,
was because we couldn't help
them get over those hurdles,
and we didn't even think
of those as necessarily
being the first hurdles.
So again, this gap
from your computer
for Netflix to your
computer for data science
is very, very real.
There was also a
misalignment, and probably
some miscommunication on my
part, about what we were doing.
So some of the biggest
things was people showed up
and they were like, what
time do classes start?
I was like, they don't.
We're just going to
read the book together,
and you're on your
own, and I'm not
going to tell you when to do
things or how to do things.
So that was a big thing.
We had people who
were like, what book?
What is the book?
So that was a little
bit lost in translation.
And then another thing
was that not everybody
was tidyverse aligned.
Now listen.
If you're having trouble
installing R and RStudio
on your computer,
I don't expect you
to know the difference between
base R and the tidyverse.
But if you're not
there to help people
learn the tidyverse, which
is a central organizing
principle of the
book, it's going
to be some rough sledding.
So there was a lot to work out.
And we also-- I didn't provide
any training for mentors.
I was like, yeah, you
know how to be a mentor.
Forget the fact that we
send teachers to school
to be certified in teaching.
I was like, pssh, you're fine.
Just be nice.
It'll be good.
It'll all work out.
So at the end of round one.
I was exhausted.
This was-- I just
want to say, people
are like, data
science is so hard.
If you want a hard job,
go be a community manager,
because that is exhausting.
If you know a community manager
in your life, give them a hug.
Thank them for what they do.
That is a thankless career,
and it is incredibly difficult.
So this happened, right?
And I was exhausted.
I didn't read the book.
I hadn't finished the book.
I was spending all of my
time answering Twitter DMs,
creating content,
answering Slack messages,
helping connect people--
so I had really moved into
a community manager role,
and it wasn't quite
what I expected.
I will say that we did have one
person who copped to finishing
the entire curriculum.
The guys at Hopkins
tell me that is well
within the margin of error and
that I should be very, very
proud of that one person.
And I am.
I am also proud of myself
for doing something
before I was ready.
And I'm really, really proud of
the people who were like, yeah,
this is a crazy idea,
but I'm going to do it.
Everybody who came along
on that first adventure,
I am incredibly proud
of for taking a risk
and trying something new.
So then people were like,
hey, when's round two?
So in round two, I was like,
I can't do this by myself.
Something needs to change.
And I said, what do you all
want to see in this community?
And people came back
with all sorts of ideas.
And when they said, I
really want to see this.
I said, that is
a fantastic idea.
How can I support you in
making that a reality?
And what that did is it resulted
in people being like, oh, no.
I don't want to do the thing.
And OK, that's great.
Then it's not going to get done.
But it also resulted
in people saying, well,
I need you to help me
to research software.
Or I need you to
retweet something.
Or I need you to just help me
talk in the group and recruit
people for this.
And those were things
that I could do.
So in round two, we had a
lot of amazing things happen.
We had commitments
to office hours
where people would give
up an hour of their week
and just show up and
answer questions.
We did GitHub.
We did the chapters
out of the book.
We had YouTube tutorial videos
that community members made.
And then three things
that you're probably
most familiar with
is we have a website,
we have a Twitter account,
and we have Tidy Tuesday.
These are not
things that I built.
I made sure everybody
got in Slack
and that everybody was happy
and well-behaved and nice
to each other.
These are things that
community members have built,
and the community members
to this day maintained.
If you want to get involved in
this online learning community,
you can go to that
website and sign up,
and I strongly
encourage you to do so.
So when we were getting
through round two,
I'm realizing that the group
isn't what I set out to do,
right?
We're not going through a
text together and necessarily
learning at a specific pace.
But it's also an
amazing community,
and people are doing
amazing things.
They're just not quite the
things that I want to do.
So I am very excited to say
that the group was handed off
to a new set of leaders
who are enthusiastic
and incredibly talented
at what they do
in keeping this group running.
And they are just--
I think they were saying that
there were over 2,500 members
today.
So the community
continues to grow.
It continues to be active.
It continues to be a
place where you can
go and give and get help in R.
So in my time away
from the group,
I started to think
about a lot of things.
And I thought a
lot about my life
and how data science
has changed my life.
Just doing this community,
just learning data science,
just being a data scientist
has changed my life.
It's changed the people
that I have access to,
it has given me opportunities
that I would never before
have had in my life, and
it has completely changed
my socioeconomic status.
Instead of living in a financial
crisis every single day
of my life, I'm
like two emergencies
away from a financial crisis.
Right?
And that's a big deal when
you grow up in poverty
and you can't put
food on the table--
to have that security.
So I was like, if data
science has done this for me,
then it can do it
for other people.
And it's my
responsibility to help
make it easier for other
people move into data science.
And I think we can all agree
that data and data science
is used every single
day about, by,
and for every single
one of us to make
choices and decisions for us.
Data is integral to
our lives, and it will
be for the foreseeable future.
So as I started to look around
data science as a whole,
and I was like,
data science affects
each and every one of us,
so each and every one of us
deserves a seat at the table.
So what I'm asking
people to do--
there is a laundry list
of a million things
I could ask you to do to start
getting more people into data
science, and making it easier to
bring people into data science,
and removing some
of the barriers.
But I'm only going to
ask you to do one thing.
I'm going to ask you
to be vulnerable.
I'm going to ask you to help
me demystify data science.
Share publicly on Twitter,
on your blog posts, in person
the things that you don't know.
Share the things
that you're learning,
and share the mistakes
that you've made.
Data science isn't special.
Data science isn't even
necessarily a difficult career.
I think the more--
there's no checklist
for data science
where we say, oh, great.
I have done every
item on this list,
and then Hadley Wickham
descends from the heavens
and knights you
a data scientist,
and everything-- now you are
free to practice data science.
Go do data science,
and share with people.
Because what data
science is is it's
about constantly learning
and growing and taking risks.
I would argue that that is one
of the defining characteristics
of being in data science, that
you're constantly learning,
you're constantly
making mistakes,
and you're constantly
learning from mistakes.
And the more that
we normalize that
and we say, hey, this is
what us, the people who get
paid to be data scientists, do--
I think the more
that we can start
bringing in diverse
voices and making data
science as a community more
equitable and inclusive.
With that, I think I might
be able to take one question?
I don't know.
Nina's my timekeeper.
OK.
[LAUGHING]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Or you don't have any
questions, and that's fine, too.
You can always reach
out to me on Twitter.
Hi.
Thanks for your talk.
And thanks for being
brave and vulnerable
and all those things.
So when you stepped
away from the community,
who was it that took
over, and what was
a part of that decision to--
Yeah, so two of the
people are in this room.
One is a gentleman
named Dennis, who is--
I can't remember the--
I think he's in Kenya.
And then we have Thomas
Mock in the back.
He has got Tidy
Tuesday stickers.
I'm just putting that out there.
And then Jon Harmon also
over here on the end.
So these are the gentlemen
that are currently
running the community
and keeping it alive
and making sure everything
is going as planned.
[MUSICAL TONE]